it's been almost a year since the
outbreak of the coronavirus pandemic
a global health emergency that has
changed all of our lives
at the end of 2019 china alerted the who
of a new
pneumonia-like illness in the city of
wuhan what followed
was an unprecedented response to contain
the deadly outbreak
the city and its 11 million people were
sealed off from the outside world
in one of the harshest lockdowns in
history the new coronavirus claimed more
than four thousand lives in wuhan
its rapid spread overwhelming medical
staff
china's response was swift new hospitals
sprang up
in a matter of weeks
remarkable scenes but nearly a year on
life here has returned to a normality
that cities outside china
can only dream of shops are open people
are out and about
and confidence in the communist party is
high
but look under the surface and all isn't
as is made out to be
it is almost as if nothing had ever
happened here
life is back to normal in the city where
the coronavirus first emerged
at the time the government reacted with
one of the most severe lockdowns in
human history
now old and young enjoy outdoor
activities
children are back in school with their
grandparents waiting to pick them up
outsiders might still have the virus but
wuhan people don't
it's because they governed well during
lockdown
china has brought infection rates down
to almost
zero in an exuberant exhibition the
communist party celebrates victory
in what it calls its war on the epidemic
with tributes to soldiers and medics
who worked themselves to exhaustion
during the outbreak
but first and foremost the party
celebrates itself
and the general secretary xi jinping was
hailed as the man who led the country to
victory
i'm very moved by this exhibition i feel
that the people of hubei province
the government and all its organizations
have shouldered a lot
[Music]
this is how china wants people to see
its reaction to the disease
and how many people do see it indeed but
there are other voices in this city
zhang hai is one of them he is on his
way to the municipal government
i think they should change their name
from the people's government of wuhan
to the bureaucrats government of wuhan
zhanghai normally lives in the southern
city of shenzhen
but returned home to wuhan in january
when his father broke his hip
the elderly man received free treatment
at a military hospital
this was where he caught covet and later
died
says his father would still be alive if
the authorities in wuhan had not covered
up the early stages of the outbreak
he is trying to file a case in court
against the government
that's my current state of mind
i can't stand all this propaganda about
the achievements in the fight against
kovid
all the people who died the innocent
people who left this world have never
been paid proper respect
but few people still speak publicly
about their grievances
many others appear to have put the
experience behind them
nightlife is back on the streets
especially young people
enjoy their newly returned freedom
i feel energized we've stored up energy
for almost half a year
i've been exercising and taking care of
my health every day
i feel healthier and more alive than
ever before
i don't feel the need to rest at all we
had a rest that was way too long there's
no excitement at home
while many places in the world still
struggle with the pandemic
the city where it all began is moving on